it is morally untenable in the United
States in my view it is medically
untenable because the medical profession
not only agrees to first do no harm but
if you read closely the Hippocratic oath
talks about justice it talks about being
a provider and a treater of an entire
patient a whole patient in context and
when that is not the case then implicit
biases change the way that people are
treated you can watch this and other
programs online at book TV org
you're watching book TV on c-span 2 with
top nonfiction books and authors every
weekend book TV television for serious
readers
and this weekend we bring you coverage
of the 13th annual national black
Writers Conference with conversations on
diversity in writing programs hip-hop
and literature race and gender and more
and that starts today and tomorrow at
1:30 p.m. Eastern on afterwards
Peter Marx talks about how the late AIG
CEO Bob Benoit che revived the company
after the 2008 financial crisis and
Pulitzer prize-winning historian Annette
gordon-reed and Jefferson's scholar
Peter oneth discussed the intellectual
maturation of Thomas Jefferson plus a
history of Jerusalem through its
contemporary architecture a look at how
a smallpox outbreak in Boston in 1721
led to the early use of inoculations
against the disease and we talked to
local authors and visit the literary
sites of San Bernardino California for
the complete television schedule go to
book TV Norg book TV 48 hours of
nonfiction books and authors television
for serious readers
welcome to San Bernardino on book TV
located in the San Bernardino Valley the
city is part of what is called the
Inland Empire of the population of over
200,000 people founded by Mormon
pioneers in 1851 San Bernardino would go
on to become a major hub for the Santa
Fe Railway and in 1940 become the
birthplace for McDonald's with the help
of our Time Warner and Charter
Communications cable partners for the
next hour we'll explore the history of
the city with local authors but first on
December 2nd of last year two people
entered a conference room at the inland
regional center and opened fire killing
14 people we spoke with councilmember
John Valdivia on his plans to build a
permanent memorial to honor the victims
just behind me here at the intersection
this was a barricaded entry point where
police and Sheriff we're here and no one
can cross the line this was this
intersection at Lorne show and Waterman
was the natural place for individuals to
place their token of memory and for
these tragic victims of the December 2nd
event well as you can see from behind me
some of the things that people left
behind
we're obviously teddy bears pictures
mementos certain objects of affection
for these victims the atmosphere grew
quite large in fact all four corners
appeared to have mourners that were just
watching waiting praying others were
nailing there was members of the clergy
in our community that were on scene
providing consolation and counseling
services and so our city was written
really experiencing a traumatic event
and our community has as a result come
together with much unity I have been of
the opinion that there needs to be an
established memorial I'd like to
certainly rename a portion of this
street to a memorial highway in honor of
December 2nd and the victim
the loss of life on that day well it
provides a sense of remembrance it
highlights their lives and what they've
contributed to our local
it always will be a near and dear place
for us to kind of provide a place of
consolation serenity
so we're thinking a serenity garden a
prayer chapel of some sort in and around
this area art community is resilient
we have really adopted the San Bernadino
strong in motto and our feeling is as
elected officials in this city is that
many of our residents and businesses
have come together United and
perspective of rebuilding this city and
this is a very important step forward as
we unite behind the Memorial and look
forward to the future
and now on book TV a literary tour of
San Bernardino California with the help
of our local cable partners Time Warner
and Charter while in San Bernardino we
spoke with Jamal nazar Dean of the
College of Social and Behavioral
Sciences at California State University
San Bernardino we talked about his book
globalization and terrorism
our thing with the history of terrorism
we will find that terrorism has been
around from time immemorial if we go
back to the legends in the holy books in
the Old Testament and the Jewish Torah
would remember cases of Samson if you
remember the story of Samson what Samson
as he was captured tortured blinded and
then wants to be fed to the Lions what
did he do he said on me on my enemy and
my enemies oh my god and he brought down
the temple
killing thousands of innocent people
perhaps what could one could say that
Samson was the first suicide killer in
history ah and it continued on and on
and on from generation to generation but
the word terror or terrorism comes from
the French Revolution in the French
Revolution after there shortly after the
Revolution we had about seven years that
were called the reign of terror were
they executed many people use the
guillotine beheaded people threw people
in the same river and so on that error
was called the reign of terror that is
where the word terrorism came out from
so it's not really something modern or
something recent or something Islamic it
has been around for forever and ever
it's been with us for a long time it
hasn't stopped them the tools have
changed over the years but the product
that had the act itself the nature of
the act the reaction of people to
oppression to violence has been with us
for a long time when people are
oppressed they're gonna rebel and when
they're involved sometimes they carry
out acts that we now call terrorism
terrorism today is not really different
than terrorism of the past except for
the tools they use the the tools that
are available nowadays are much more
destructive you can get on an airplane
and have the airplane go into a building
that didn't exist in the past what we
had in the past is individuals going
with their sword or what they're going
to kill many other many innocent people
today you can kill a lot more by having
a bomb attached to your chest or you're
carrying it in your handbag and if
you're desperate enough to kill yourself
and the others you're gonna be killing a
lot more people than they would have in
history and so terrorism today is is
more violent than the past it is more
severe has a greater impact on civilians
and because of the media it generates
greater amount of fear among people in
the past people heard stories becomes
overtime legends almost because I time
their treaties another Society
nowadays is instantaneous the media
tells us right away bombing and Brussels
bombing in Pakistan romping in France
and you know it's instant we see it
right away because of TV because of you
know media because of communications and
therefore people become scared become
afraid you know right here in San
Bernardino we had terrorist attack back
in December December 2nd and my own
daughter works for the county and my own
daughter was there and she was terrified
then and she continues to be terrified
till today she was in the midst of it
not where the shooting happened but in
the building nearby she was stranded
held up for about five hours it has an
impact it brings fear in the hearts of
other people the way it became Islamic
you know it was the rise of the
Mujahideen
Afghanistan under President Ronald
Reagan we recruited the Mujahideen we
recruited people from the Arabian
Peninsula from North Africa from
different places to go to Afghanistan to
fight the old Soviet Union was occupying
Afghanistan in the name of Islam and
then after the war was over and we
forgot about Afghanistan they stayed
there on their base the word base in
Arabic is Qaeda so that was the
beginning of al-qaeda we in essence were
the contributing factor that brought
that about and then they got a very
upset at us because we abandoned them
they tried to go back to their home
countries their home countries in wonnum
armed opposing their system because
they've become so devoted to their
version of Islam and they felt very
stranded and abandoned and they tried to
take revenge of the United States and
September 11 happened the invasion of
Iraq brought on the current wave under
Isis or ISIL or the Islamic state of
Syria and the Iraq Iraq and Syria if we
didn't have a war in Iraq they would
have not been an Isis if we didn't help
the Mujahideen in Afghanistan they would
not have been al Qaeda so in a way we
have the hand in creating these types of
groups when we went to Iraq we bomb we
bombed the country we called it shock
and awe furor and Iraqi trying to raise
your children trying to take them to
school feed them and do your job and
raise your family and all of a sudden
you see these b-52s dropping bombs the
bombs are falling down what do you do
you look up and say god help me
when people are scared they go back to
God they go back to religion and then we
say oh the Iraqis all of a sudden now
are Islamists well we push them there we
made them terrified
and when people are terrified they pray
they go back to God religion becomes a
greater part of their lives and as a
result now they recruit people who are
upset about the situation whatever it
may be that situation somebody who lost
an uncle or an aunt
perhaps the killers in San Bernardino
husband and wife the wife is new arrival
from Pakistan the husband from here went
back to Pakistan and brought her with
him perhaps she lost somebody maybe to
one of our bondings in northern
Afghanistan Pakistan on the border with
Afghanistan she got very frustrated and
she wanted to get back at us when she
saw this Afghan at this Pakistani
American coming in maybe she hooked up
with him in order to come here in order
to carry out some act so there must be
something we don't know the details
there must be something my guess is that
the wife was the instigator behind it
and must have been something happening
in her situation we do bomb in their
country we have drones that drop bombs
on leaders of Islamist groups in
Pakistan as well as in Afghanistan she
may have lost a relative she may have
been frustrated by losing a friend she
may have been frustrated by something
else leaving her two to be determined to
take revenge to show the Americans
somehow what is happening in Europe is
that we're beginning to have more Isis
attacks in European cities and I think
the reason for that is that the bombing
campaign in Syria and Iraq we have
European countries joining in in the
bombing campaign also in Libya when the
people some people rebelled in Libya
immediately the European Union NATO the
European Union and NATO joined in and
began to bomb in Libya
they declared the no-fly zone but they
could fly and bomb and bringing down
Qaddafi actually murdering him at the
end and many people didn't forgive the
Europeans for that
and the Europeans become a target and
also the coverage as I mentioned in the
media when in France the incidents
happened you know big media big groups
people leaders from all over the world
going to Paris flags that have staff you
and Security Council meeting and
condemning but these acts happen all the
time in Nigeria they happen all the time
in Kenya they happen all the time in
Somalia in Pakistan and Afghanistan the
Europeans don't move they don't care
they don't call for a Security Council
resolution to condemn these acts and
people feel why am i lesser than others
and they get very frustrated and then
the Europeans become a target in a way
because of that plus the racism the anti
Islamic racism that we find in Europe
nowadays that contributes to targeting
Europeans and we're beginning to see
similar things in this country with with
this election cycle the anti Islamic
attitude in this country as if all
Muslims are terrorists somehow or could
become terrorists is it's really
outrageous to label one and a half
million people on earth by the behavior
of the few and in if it's Timothy
McVeigh doink Oklahoma City bombing
killing all these people including
children its Timothy McVeigh we know him
we know his background we know his
family we know as a religion we know
everything about them but if it is a
Muslim who does such an act it's
immediately Islamic terrorism we don't
know much about the individual we don't
know much about the family or the
background or anything it's we label
one-and-a-half million people
the behavior of the one or the 19 it's
wrong very wrong you cannot do that
otherwise who will be labeled the
labeling Christians because some
Christian went to a theater and started
shooting or went to a school and started
shooting that will be wrong to put all
the people together and label them by
the behavior of the one or the view and
we're doing that in this country now
when when the shooting took place in San
Bernardino here in our town where we're
at now I was at the restaurant and I saw
it on TV
and what went through my mind
immediately is my daughter not only this
it was my daughter cuz she works for the
county and my daughter was in that area
and she was held up because of it of
course and she was terrified so that was
the first thing our as a father do you
worry about your children first but then
as an American a Palestinian Arab
American I'm not Muslim either I'm
Catholic actually as as an American Arab
American I got very worried that the
shooter or shooters may be Arab or
Muslim thank God they weren't Arab
they're Pakistani but they're Muslim and
that contributes to labeling the whole
group by the act of these two and it did
so but this community has been a
fantastic community the Muslims of the
Inland Empire San Bernardino and the
area's rounded collected almost two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
the victims when Muslims had priors on
Friday after the shooting Christian and
Jewish ministers and rabbis and many
people came instead and stood in front
of the mosque so the Muslims could pray
in peace inside I love this community
this is an example for all of our
three this is how we should be work
together as a community protect each
other as a community and not think of
the act of the one or the few as an act
of the whole and our community did very
well with that I'm very proud of San
Bernardino community for what they have
done this book has been very good has
done very well actually when it came out
it received a choice outstanding book
Book of the Year award so it has been
recognized but it is recognized because
it gives the perspectives not only of
the powerful but the perspective of
those who are on the other side who are
on the receiving end of the powerful I
think that is the biggest message that I
need people to know that hey the other
side whom we call a terrorist also has
grievances also may have some rights
that we need to recognize be aware of
that we no matter how great we are we do
some things wrong like when we go and
invade the country and bomb their people
to smithereen we do something wrong in
doing that so that the notion of my
country love it or leave it is in my
opinion a form of stupidity it is our
duty as Americans and I became
naturalized American long long time ago
back in the middle sixties I became an
American wouldn't be and when I became
American I have to pass a test and in
that test I learned that it is my duty
to correct my country when I see my
country deviate from what is right when
my country does wrong it is my job to
try to correct it so I will never say my
country right or wrong if my country is
wrong it's my job to correct it and
that's what we need to do that's the
kind of message and like readers of this
book to get that we have a duty as
citizens of this great country I I love
this country but I hate some of its
policies and I keep trying
working hard to correct them that is
what we need to do to correct the
policies of our country that have gone
in the wrong direction
many of those are listening and watching
this program I hope not too many I hope
it's only a few who will be thinking
that this professor is just a radical
who is justifying terrorism I'm not
justifying terrorism I oppose terrorism
I think it is all sorts of violence
I think terrorism is counterproductive
in the long run and it is outrageous and
we need to find ways around it but we
don't need to be helping created we have
helped create terrorism and we need to
find ways around it I do not justify
terrorism I do not support terrorism but
I understand the motives that push
people to terrorism that doesn't mean I
accept it or I agree with it or I
support it I do not I hope that someday
we'll get beyond our nationalistic
attitudes and begin to look and the
better betterment of all human beings
and the rights of all human beings and
recognize that what divides us is simply
an accident of birth I didn't choose to
be born in Jerusalem and the Palestinian
wanted a Christian family I did not
choose that that's an accident of birth
that doesn't make me lesser than any
other human being or more than any other
human being and if we recognize that and
begin to work on the basis of that
that's all life is precious all human
beings are important regardless of their
accident of birth then we will be
serving society in the long run you're
watching book TV on c-span 2 this
weekend were in San Bernardino
California with the help of our local
cable partners charter and Time Warner
up next historian Nick Cataldo Raquel
the time the white herb plant spent in
the city
when people hear of the name herb the
first thing they think about is that he
was part of the Old West some say he was
a bad man some say he was a good man
but they all heard his name mentioned
and Wyatt Earp is the one that they
remember most of all the connection that
the herbs have to Seminole County serves
back to about 1852 when the father of
Wyatt Earp who is the most well known of
the Earp's his name is Nicholas or he
was basically left his family
temporarily they were living in Monmouth
Illinois he heard about the gold rush up
in Northern California and after
spending a couple years up at in what it
was called hang town now it's called
Placerville yeah it's in the gold rush
company country he before he came back
went back to the Midwest he ventured
down to Southern California he never
really gave a reason why but but he did
and he passed through the San Bernardino
Valley and he vowed that one day he
would come back to San Mateo and
thirteen years later that's what
happened May of 1864 Nicholas herb
because he had been out here before he
was named the wagon master and was four
families that came out the herbs it was
a Nicholas and his wife Virginia Anne
there was James who was it one of the
well second oldest brother he was just
discharged from the Union Army Wyatt
Earp was sixteen years old and there was
Morgan Warren and ideally it was three
years old so looks very odd there's
about four brought four boys and a girl
and there are three other families that
came with him so they're about twelve
wagons all together in this Caravan and
and Nick ARP was the wagon master took
him all over seven months you know
travel back then was slow in fact quite
often people were walking alongside the
wagons so you can only walk so fast
which means that the wagons probably
went about two miles an hour they
arrived on December 19th 1864 Saturday
with San Bernardino the city
1,500 people it was surely after the
Mormons were recalled back to Salt Lake
and Sammartino turned into a when I
guess what people call a wild west town
and in fact the corner of 3rd and D
Street was nicknamed whiskey point
because they had a saloon at each corner
and so it was kind of I guess exciting
if that's what you know if you're into
the Old West and Nicholas herb even
though his family
they settled a few miles away from town
he loves Sanford you know he liked that
kind of entertainment when they arrived
they settled in in Samer do you know
they they camp in a park it's a park in
town called metal book park but at the
time was just a little swampy area there
for a few days and then nikkor Nicholas
are rented a form from a name carpenter
about 12 miles east of town and what is
now consider to be Redlands north part
of Redlands at the time they called it
old San Bernardino and they really they
lived as a makes their life of farmers
they lived there and they moved to
another ranch another farm a couple
miles away and that's what the father
did was a farmer Wyatt Earp according to
his biographer Stewart Lake hope is
called wider frontier Marshalls written
1931
it's basically that's the book that kind
of created the legend of Wyatt Earp and
the problem it's a beautifully written
book there's a lot of historical
accuracy but is also a lot of inaccuracy
it's hard to tell which is which
but according to Lake and also a friend
of Wyatt's name is John flood who had
written a manuscript that never got
published Wyatt as a teenager drove a I
was involved with a stagecoach route
from San Bernardino to Los Angeles and
also as above was frating Virgil Earp
was the first city marshal of Colton so
that would be something about more
importance but if he was to
marshall and nicholas urfe was a justice
of the peace so that was kind of the big
role
Nicholas herb the father of the family
decided he decided in 1868 to sell some
property had here and moved back to the
Midwest now there wasn't one possibility
that Nicholas herb was not happy that
his his sons really did not want it for
him he was the farmer and nobody else
wanted the farm
Nicholas herb the father was a he was a
adventurer he loved to he loved doing
getting involved with a lot of stuff his
sons were the same way so they had this
this urge to do other things and not
just be a farmer also he had some land
he needs to take care of in the Midwest
out in in Iowa and also Missouri because
at one time dealers in Missouri
so there were a combination of reasons
they then you had to go back to Midwest
but he was playing and coming back again
so they left in 1868 then 1877 1876 77
they start coming out west and
eventually came back into this area and
when Nicholas herb came out in 1877 the
members of this family that came out was
his wife his daughter Adelia who just
got married she was 16 years old
and and also her her husband came out
James no no wasn't it was a warrant herb
the youngest boy came out and that was
it
house they were coming out west they
stopped in Dodge City Kansas and by then
Wyatt Earp was working on a police force
there he worked it worked as a deputy
deputy city marshal and Morgan Earp was
there and so already the you know the
boys are getting older and they were
adventury the only one that went was
warrant up and that's he was kind of a
tragic story he was a youngest boy he
was up all the boys had a temper you
know they they they had to urge to
travel they were they were just picked
up a lot of traits from [ __ ] and the
boys had a temper but they for the most
part they were able to curb
temper Wyatt Earp is very known for his
coolness warrant Earp the youngest one
was a hothead and he got all kinds of
problems and they want him to stay close
to home when the OK Corral happened on
October 26 1881 during this time Morgan
Earp was up in Montana he went down to
Temescal in 1880 after leaving Montana
when he came down 1880 the Earp's
he had already heard about this gold the
silver strike in Tombstone Wyatt was in
Dodge City first he was a Wichita than
Dodge City Kansas and and Virgil Earp
and another brother a little older than
Wyatt he was a sheriff of Yavapai County
in Arizona and he heard about this
silver strike and the herbs are ever the
opportunist they all made plans to get
together in Tombstone so James Earp came
down from Montana Wyatt was I was in
Dodge City Kansas and eventually Morgan
who had just come down from Montana went
to Temescal left to go to Tombstone
October 26 1881 is the day of this if
Miss gunfight at the OK Corral a very
complex situation but that's what really
gave wider the notoriety not always good
though fact they you know newspapers
after an event they knew of there herbs
as being either good guys are killers
quite often to consider to be the other
way well meanwhile Nikolas Earp was
living in Colton because after leaving
10s Cole they moved to Colton which is a
for about 4 miles from San Bernardino
and there was the only thing I know as
far as the impact you had here is that
about a month after the gunfight and
about a month before his son Virgil was
ambushed in in in Tombstone there was a
retaliation Nicholas sort of got into
arguments with somebody with that and
there was John Ralph's it was County
Sheriff and there was another man and
all sudden you know there was an
altercation he
something happened he blew his stack
know whether or not that every don't
want you spent speculate that maybe I
had something to do with your sons were
you know you know it all depends you
know because it yeah you know they
basically were exonerated for killing
these yeah
the members of the Clanton gang but some
people still thought that they were on
the bad side when I said Nicholas herb
came with the Temescal the father
and then they moved to in 1880 moved to
Colton basically for the rest of his
life he lived in and Colton Colton and
owned some land in San Bernardino the
wife was buried at Pioneer Cemetery
she died in Sanford you know Nicholas
herb the father died in Sawtelle so a
military hospital near in Los Angeles
County but basically he was living in
this area
samer do you know and it was living in
last years with his daughter who moved
to Yucaipa which is nearby town and
Colton Morgan while he was killed in
Tombstone Loren lived most of his life
here so really that herbs
spent most of their time living in San
Bernardino County more than any other
place even the most recent movies about
the Earp's was a 1993 the movie called
Tombstone started started up Kurt
Russell and very good I have the movie
and and I think you know compared to
their older movies it was probably more
accurate in a lot of ways and so there
were some inaccuracies the next year
Kevin Costner was a movie called Wyatt
Earp again a lot of historical facts
that were never brought out before still
inaccurate though in some ways but in
both cases after the gunfight okay
Corral
there was a short time later they didn't
say exactly base it was two months later
what Virgil Earp was injured he was
ambushed and about three months later
after that march of eighty to nineteen
1882 Morgan Earp was killed Morgan's
body was sent on a train going out
somewhere you know you know be they see
I think one this
California turnout they went to Colton
which is never sandwiches you know and
so they never mentioned that and in fact
even in a movie Wyatt Earp
it showed a Gene Hackman was playing the
father
part of the father and they were talking
about moving to California they never
mentioned her going to Sandra's you know
I just I just didn't and that's just
what it is you know the notoriety the
the thing that people really attracted
to about the herbs is a time in
Tombstone and basically they're only
there for about two years but it was
very eventful two years but but most of
the time the family was out in the San
Bernardino Valley or the county
especially right this area right here
you're watching book TV on c-span 2 and
this weekend were visiting San
Bernardino California to talk with local
authors and tour the city's literary
sites with the help of our local cable
partners Time Warner and charter up next
we speak with Richard Thompson about
Aaron G Lane the first permanent
settlers of the high desert
well we're on the edge of the Mojave
Desert 20 miles from cone pass and the
significance is this was the major route
to cut to the west to California in the
early years of course there wasn't
anybody out on the desert all of the all
of settlement was down down below along
the coast and in 1859 the first
permanent resident came to this spot and
his name was Aaron Lane he was so well
known in fact the newspapers started
calling him pioneer of the Mojave which
is what I called my book because even in
his own time when he was still alive
they were saying where comes Aaron Lane
he's the pioneer of the Mojave and he
came because of health reasons but this
was 45 or 50 miles out of San Bernardino
that would have been the next closest
spot from here but by by coming out here
everybody around this area you've got
this far and maybe their wagons broke
down he had a
blacksmith shop livery stable and so
they could repair their wagons feed
their horses feed themselves so this was
came to be what was called a weigh
station in those days life in this area
well there there weren't hardly anybody
he I think talked another couple in San
Fernando coming out with him because we
find them in the 1860 census a couple by
the name of Highmore and they had a
little girl and other people started
coming but originally there were just
maybe two male adults here and the
Indians had been used to going through
and they didn't like the idea that you
know what looked like a colony was
starting out here he got attacked
several times by Indians and they got a
hold it in a couple of times and and
stole all of his worldly goods
it didn't kill it just didn't kill him
he was fortunate keeping his life but
one of the first instances that took
place in 1859 March of 1859 was an
outlaw that had been chased from the LA
area and this fellow named Wade helm
Wade helm had a bounty placed on his
head by the governor
so the but the posse was chasing him out
of LA lost him and I'm 40 and then
somebody from San Bernardino met up with
the philosophy since well they saw him
going up and calling fast so the posse
came up and they found him here and
lanes with another guy named mace I
don't know what the last name where that
is his last thing but that's a pretty
good name for an outlaw I think mace and
so they surrounded the place the guns
were out and ready to go and then the
two the two outlaws finally gave up when
he let when he let Wade Hellman mace in
and others these others that I'm talking
about probably wasn't sure he could
suspect that he had to keep an eye on
these guys but he had a reputation for
being good with a gun the military was
having trouble with the Indians out here
prior to the Civil War and they'd put
some camps out along the Mojave River
Camp Katie being the first one down here
and thrown over two needles were that we
had fort Mojave well when the war
started the Civil War they needed all
the soldiers to you know they didn't
have any excess soldiers so they brought
them all call them all in off the desert
and that's when things got pretty wild
out here the Indians had been fighting
the whites and when the whites all
disappeared all the soldiers left
they thought they were winning
and when all the forts shut down they
were pretty sure they were winning so it
made it really bad for any of the
occupants that were here so that
military was a different caliber there
was a story of one group coming through
and had talked about they would go to a
certain person and these names were all
given in the newspaper of who they who
they molested but they would go to a
ranchers property and shoot his lambs
for just so they could eat mutton and
they ate it right in front of him you
know cooked it up prepared it they would
go into stores and and just grocery
stores and start loading up and just
walking out with it and I mentioned the
newspaper articles mentioned that the
officers were standing standing right
there watching him do it so we had a
different class of art of officer in a
different classes of enlisted men so
these people would come through
periodically and they would come through
and fern a large companies maybe 75 or
100 men and they pretty much had their
way but the newspapers mentioned on
several occasions when they got out here
there was Elaine had a reputation for
not putting up with that stuff and he
was ready for him he said and he told
the newspaper that and they didn't
bother him well Aaron Lane his impact on
this area was pretty profound it was his
time and place as being the first man
and the Mojave Desert to stay here
permanently and that shows his
importance as a stabilizing event
you know he started things here and
transferred to civilization
during book TV's recent visit to San
Bernardino California
we spoke with Margaret Hill about her
30-year career as an educator in the
city
in the early 70s when I started teaching
students were aware that it was
important for them to it was important
to get an education it was important to
get a high school diploma I think
students I don't I don't think I've ever
met a student who did not want in
education I know I've met a lot of
students who felt the way I did when I
was a student that not too many people
cared whether I got it or not
and when I'm talking about caring not
parents or siblings but I'm talking
about those working in the school
environment and I think students in the
70s
felt the same way students now feel some
of them just feel they don't fit in and
because we aren't telling them they fit
in we are telling them how important
they are
we aren't telling them of their
strengths and we are telling them about
their forefathers who did it and if they
could do it we can do it also it affects
them a lot more than the people that the
higher level realize even with me
sometimes I do things that I know has
not been good I'm thankful that people
trust me enough that they can say what
they want to to me let me give an
example of what we do to our students
and not realize when I was the principal
at an alternative high school had a
young man he come up to me one day and
he said to me miss Hill I have seen you
give a lot of students compliments he
said you've never given me one and I
thought about that and he was right and
and I knew I hadn't given him one
because he reminded me of that otherwise
life would have been the same and he
would have graduated from high school
thinking knowing I didn't really care
for him
but I thought about it and I said he's
right I said I have to give him a
compliment and I have to give it to him
and soon and I have to have an audience
so believe it or not the
next day I can still remember he had on
a yellow checkered shirt and it was a
beautiful shirt I knew I had to find
something I could compliment him on
didn't know it was gonna come so soon so
I waited until he I saw him all day long
didn't say anything to him at the end of
the day when he was leaving as he as you
do with most other students you know
you're pretty much in a group he was
leaving school and I yelled his name he
turns around gives me this look like
what have I done now that you don't like
and I yelled I waited until he got
halfway across the parking lot so I
could yell at him and I yelled at him
and I said I like that shirt you wearing
today that is really a good-looking
shirt and he smiled and said thank you
mrs. Hill and walked on so I was glad
that that was an immediate fix but a lot
of students don't share what they feel
about us and how they feel about us two
maybe two or three school board meetings
ago we had a young man to come in and he
had done a survey of the student of some
students over 200 students on this
campus and out of the survey most of the
students are over 50% of the students
felt no one cared about them and that's
a tremendous bit on a young person and
they they have to know we care they have
to know we care do I think on the
federal level state regionally known and
local level are we doing enough for our
students I don't think that they will
come that we will ever do enough anytime
you have
anything less than zero percent of
students being successful we are not
doing enough funding is important to all
I have a saying in my district that
students do not leave a good thing
students and in these the scenario that
I always use is school students see
schools like they see grandmas you know
you have two grandmothers one is cooking
broccoli and one is baking cookies which
place are you going and I said it's the
same thing with school if the charter
schools are making cookies and we are
cooking broccoli you know where are they
going and the thing is we began to make
some cookies now so we see some charter
school students returning the bottom
line is everybody is searching for the
best for their for their children I am a
supporter of public schools because I
I've worked in them and I know what the
accomplishments are and I know there are
some students who do not quite make it I
know many students do make it but as far
as the funding is concerned I'm glad
there's funding you know for both I'm
glad there's funding for both and I
think what people need to do is not too
much look at the academic side as to put
in a child in charter school because one
what that does many times and many times
people take a look at test scores of our
students which bothers me tremendously
and as an educator I probably should not
say that but it does because test scores
do not define students you know students
define students and I think when we
accept them and take them where they are
we need to be a proud of where they're
going where they are they're our success
and I know I know a millionaire
who never graduated from high school who
probably the score in the bottom two
percentile on a standardized test but I
also know students who have graduated
with great reading scores great test
scores and they're working in jobs that
kind of menial so I think we need to
take a look at individuals and use all
kinds of assessments and I'm not saying
tests assessments not good but it's not
the total thing that we should look at
you know for our our young people we can
fix this it's very simple all we have to
do is appreciate everybody for every day
that God gives them the strength to get
up and get out and go to school
during book TV's recent visit to San
Bernardino we visited with Mark Landis
author of Arrowhead Springs California's
ideal resort to discuss the role that
the springs has played in the growth of
the city
where we're standing now is we're at the
entrance to the arrowhead Springs hotel
this entrance is relatively modern with
respect to the entire history of the
hotel the original entrance was a few
hundred feet south of here
and behind me you see our friend chief
type booth who is one of the most famous
landmarks of the area and he is pointing
toward Arrowhead Springs these his as
long as he's been in existence he has
always been there to point this way to
Arrowhead Springs as the American
settlers started to come into the San
Bernardino Valley and settle the area
they found the hot springs which had
long since been discovered by the
Indians but they came up here and they
started to explore and they saw the
value of the springs but it still was
too rugged and too dense for them to
really make good use of the property in
1851 the Mormons arrived in Southern
California and began to settle in the
San Bernardino Valley here and they had
established a town a well established
town in 1857 the Mormons were called
back to Salt Lake by Brigham Young and
in 1857 that same year that they were
called back and gentleman by the name of
David Noble Smith arrived here and he
had originally arrived here with the
intention of selling goods and things to
the Mormons as they were departing going
back to going back to Salt Lake City so
Smith began to come up here and explore
the area and Smith was also a very
devout spiritualist and he believed in
the healing properties of of water and
so forth and so well he had grown up
with the the the disease of tuberculosis
throughout his family and the disease
had killed many people in his family and
he had throughout his young life he had
really kind of made up his mind that he
wanted to find a cure for tuberculosis
so when he was here he thought this
would be an ideal spot to start as a spa
to develop a place for a tuberculosis
sanitarium so he worked with John
Brown's senior who had homesteaded the
property and actually began to come up
here and create a
senate's his first sanitarium which was
first opened for to the public in 1864
so in two years ago in 2014 was a
hundred and fiftieth anniversary of the
commercial use of Arrowhead Springs one
of the interesting things about the area
and Arrowhead Springs itself is how the
how the arrowhead Springs Resort got its
name now there's a huge Arrowhead
landmark on the side of the mountain
it's about four 1400 feet tall and it's
in the shape of an of an Indian
Arrowhead pointing downward and the tip
of the arrowhead pointing downward
actually points right to where the
various hot and cold springs are and
since it's in the shape of a natural
arrowhead the springs at their foot at
the foot of the arrowhead took the name
Arrowhead Springs and so the Arrowhead
landmark itself too was a major
promotional feature of the whole area
the all of the advertising made
extensive use of that landmark and they
took most of the photos would have the
lat the arrowhead landmark in the
background and so it was it was really
quite a major piece of the local
tradition here to promote the arrowhead
landmark when when Smith first came here
and developed the springs it was really
just a set of crude shacks it was very
rudimentary facilities he had some
bathhouse facilities and it was actually
very very crude just a couple of
elongated buildings eventually in 1883
he lost control of the property because
of financial troubles and a group of Los
Angeles businessmen bought the property
and actually the this was the first time
that anybody with any money or real
financing had owned the property here at
Arrowhead Springs they built a
full-fledged hotel here it was a very
first hotel on the property that was
built in 1883 and they opened it and it
was a pretty big success they built a
actually they used Smith's pond which he
had already built they had a pond out in
front of the hotel and it was a little
rowing pond and they also used that for
some of their water treatments they
would actually immerse the people in
this
in this pond that was fed by a hot
spring but the hotel like the like the
subsequent hotels would end tragically
in fire and it burned in 1885
so the Los Angeles businessmen and the
owners of the hotel quickly rebuilt the
hotel and they rebuilt an even better
hotel bigger and better hotel basically
at the same location as the first hotel
so now we had the second hotel on the
property
now that hotel was even more successful
because it was bigger and better but the
boom of the 1800s of the 1880s was
relatively short-lived it didn't last
too long
toward the last part of the 1880s it
started to fizzle out and so the times
weren't so good but still people came up
and visited Arrowhead Springs by that
time the the resort was promoted less as
a health resort and more as a
recuperation and rest resort so people
would come up here to rest and
recuperate but they always had a full
medical staff on on facility here for
the visitors that would come to
Arrowhead Springs so the era ii
Arrowhead Springs Hotel was enlarged and
it got bigger and better and in 1895 the
second hotel burned down so it was due
to what they called mishandled fireworks
at the time it burned down on July 4th
1918 95 after the second hotel burned in
1895 remember the great boom era of the
1880s was over and the economic times
were very difficult when the second
hotel burned so after the second hotel
burned it actually the property sat
basically idle for about ten years but a
lot of the folks down in the San
Bernardino Valley knew of the Arrowhead
Springs and they knew of its Worth and
they were they were not happy the fact
that their their resort was gone and
there was nothing here to draw the folks
back up here as a resort but in 1904 in
that timeframe a group of San Bernardino
businessmen got together and formed a
company formed a corporation and bought
the property and decided to rebuild a
brand new hotel they
a bigger better hotel a nice three-story
hotel that was opened in 1905 and that
was that hotel was actually designed by
an architect named Arthur B Benton who
also designed the Mission Inn and who's
very famous for the the mission style
architecture all around through Southern
California so the third hotel had some
real famous architecture involved with
it it was the third and biggest hotel it
was the most elegant and it was the by
far the largest and most successful of
any of the hotels that had been there by
by far to date so in 1905 the owners
really began to promote the hotel as a
place of rest and recuperation as well
they built all sorts of new facilities
around the hotel bath facilities steam
cave facilities all sorts of additional
facilities there and in that third hotel
the guests would come and they would be
drawn by the water because they still
advertised the water here they said you
know come to Arrowhead Springs and be
healed by the water there's all these
different types of water here that are
very health inducing for you so come
here and be healed by the water and it
really drew a lot of folks to that third
hotel and finally after so many folks
would come to the to the hotel and say
we really would like to take some of
this water home so the hotel would
package it up for him and send it home
for them to their to their relatives and
so forth and in the other states in the
eastern states and finally somebody got
the bright idea you know this would
probably be a good product to bottle
commercially in in large quantity since
it was so available and was so popular
so in 1909 the first real major bottling
facility came to be here at Arrowhead
Springs the third hotel that was built
in 1905 really began to catch on with
the Hollywood movie stars because
Hollywood was just evolving at that time
the motion picture NIT picture industry
was really just taking hold in Hollywood
in the early 1900s they had found
Southern California because of the great
weather and and year-round filming
ability of the location and all the
geography so the film industry was
really starting to take hold in around
1905 1910 that type of timeframe and so
the folks that were there
in Hollywood wanted a place that they
could that they could get away from town
and they found Arrowhead Springs that
you know it was built in 1905 so it was
a brand new facility it was beautiful
luxurious hotel and it was just far
enough out of town just far enough away
from Hollywood it was about a two-hour
drive via old Foothill Boulevard along
the foothills to Arrowhead Springs the
third hotel was was the most successful
of all the hotels but in 1938 like the
previous two hotels the third hotel was
destroyed by a wildfire that burned
through the area in driven in part like
the Santa Ana winds so then a group of
Hollywood moguls formed a consortium to
build the current and fourth hotel when
the fourth and current Hotel was built
and the new pool was built they built a
completely new pool and it was a
beautiful Art Deco style pool with
scalloped edges it was built along with
the new hotel that was opened in 1939
and the pool was was really a landmark
piece of the whole resort it really it
really began to seriously decline in the
late 1950s by that